well I always wonder why Kings Gambit
has not been played oftenly at top level
as well as in the world championship
matches guess what few months back I got
my answer and in today's video not only
you are going to learn one of the most
trickiest line against the Kings campit
but overall you get a surprise weapon
against this deadly Gambit which you
might want to consider in the tourament
practice after E4 E5 and F4 we have the
king's Gambit on the table and the
variation I have choose start with
D5 considered as a fork beer counter
Gambit now the main move here is e
captures D5 however at the below 2,000
white can try other moves as well so
first let's check out them and find out
how we can refute
them the first move I want to consider
is f captures
E5 basically a blunder in the opening as
after just one move queen
chair white can pack his back and go
home well it's true because if he play
G3 then we have this lovely check
nabbing the rook in the corner and if
white decide to start walking the king
in the park then we have this queen
check and after King to F2 and Bishop to
C5 more or less game can be finished at
the opening
stage the second move I want to consider
is Knight to F3 and against all of this
sideline moves we are going to continue
with e captures F4 where if white
continue with e captures D5 then after
Knight to F6 we enter into the mainline
so the other popular choice is E5 which
I'm afraid again leads to the opening
disaster for white as black has a very
nice attacking move here namely G5
so the threat is very obvious we want to
play G4 and then deliver this check
something which white need to address
immediately for example let's say if
they continue with the Top Choice from
the database namely D4 then black can
execute this plan perfectly with G4 so
that if the Knight moves then we can
deliver this check and misplace white
king so so that is not a good idea and
after
G4 majority of the games continue with
the peace sacrifice starting with Bishop
takes F4 but I don't believe in this as
after e takes F3 Queen takes F3 and now
the star moon Bishop to E6 where upon
black has a straightforward idea and I
don't see a single compensation for the
loss of peace
so this is the reason why white need to
address the issue of G4 here and many of
you thinks that hang on he can play H3
and diffuse All Black's threat well
guess what yep he can accept one problem
that after Knight
to6 our Knight find a heaven in the
white Camp something white has to live
with it for the rest of the game so all
in all these positions are quite fun to
play as a
black the third move I want to consider
is Knight to
C3 and you know the answer yep taking on
F4 where white has two choices if he
continue with Knight to F3 stopping over
Queen check then black can simply take
on e4 and after Knight takes
E4 black emerg with a clear Pawn
advantage and on top of everything there
is a big trap here which goes as follow
Queen to
E7 so white has to play Queen to E2 and
after this Knight to C6 sets up an
amazing trap that the most popular
choice from the database D4 is
completely prevent here
as after Bishop to F5 white got a
completely lost position at the opening
stage why well the answer is very
obvious White Knight get attacked and
when the Knight moves we have this
deciding blow Knight to B4 where there
is no stopping on
C2 so most probably black will munch
another Pawn and come out as a
completely dominating position in this
line the second tactical option white is
having here is Knight captures D5
allowing this queen
check but after G3 and pawn takes G3 I
think it is black who is getting all the
fun in this line
as we get some obvious tactical sequence
Knight to F3 attacking the queen black
plays G2 a check so White Knight has to
take it and when black queen reappears
on the board munching with the Rook
white is also delighted because he can
deliver this check and after King to d8
and Knight captures
eight we have a very funny position
where both the corner Rook disappear
from the board but it is black who has
the last love with this deciding check
so he's going to pick up yet another
piece and come out as a complete peace
Advantage middle game where after some
consolidation and careful play a full
point in the
back the fourth move I want to consider
is
D4 a somewhat complicated move but as I
mentioned earlier we are going to be
very consistent with e captures F4 where
our threat is Queen to H4 check and if
white is foolish enough to play either
of this move let's say E5 then we have
this queen check which more or less
Force white king to start walking at the
opening stage
so no that's not a good idea and
accordingly white should play Bishop to
F4 stopping of a nasty check except one
problem that it costed a vital Pawn
which we are more than happy to grab it
and I don't think so you need any other
Theory from here just play some
practical moves and dominate the
position with a clear Pawn
advantage
last but not least what to do against
the move
D3 okay we are going to take on F4 and
after Bishop takes F4 we can liquidate
the center with de captures E4 whereupon
white has two choices if he routinely
capture back then after the queen
exchange this end game really favors the
black in the view of white has misplaced
King and he has an isolated Pawn on the
E file which can be a clearcut Target in
the upcoming end game so no that's not
the right idea in this
position the most accurate choice is
Knight to
C3 allowing black to take on D3 so at
least you get some development of the
pieces but but black is not a fool and
accordingly I think the correct
responses you continue with Bishop to B4
pin down this night and concentrate on
your own peace
development a sample line can goes like
this queen to D2 stopping Black to give
white a double
Pawn okay we are going to play Knight to
F6 trying to Castle on the king side and
and when the opposite side Castle
scenario
happen we are going to see a very
important tactical pattern which goes as
follow A3 Bishop takes C3 Queen takes C3
and now you play Knight to D5 so that
after Queen D2 Knight takes F4 Queen
takes F4 and finally Queen to D5 with
the clear intention to penetrate on the
White Queen side
well in the leeches database one of the
high-profile games goes as Follow White
plays King to B1 black plays Bishop to
E6 renewing the threat so white is
forced to play
C4 but after Queen to F5 when the Queens
are getting exchanged if you see the end
result yep the material is balanced but
the most important feature is this
isolated weakness on e4 which can be a
clear-cut Target in the upcoming end
game okay so with this small video I
hope I have clear all of your doubts
that why white should play here e capsus
D5 where in the next part you are going
to see the modern theory on this line
with e captures F4 threatening Queen que
to
H4 so white has to play Knight to F3 and
after Knight to
F6 we reach to the most important
Junction of this Gambit where as I have
shown by the arrows these are the
popular choices by
W and kindly watch most important part
two to get the full knowledge of this
line with some obviously cool tricks and
traps
thank you for watching this video and
feel free to like subscribe and
comment